thank you
my favorite Cinema is very visually
driven it's not like a play It's like a
dream it's just a pure emotion
this film's a Melting Pot of movies I
grew up loving
a Vietnam movie mixed with robotic
sci-fi they've come for the child
Gareth has this ability to inject
compassion in a Sci-Fi genre that
usually leans on spectacle and danger
Gareth Edwards he is a Visionary and
these characters are all relatable and
you fall in love with them oh my God
sign me up I want to be a part of this
what jumped out was a magical realism
that he was able to execute
the depth and emotion that he was able
to capture in every frame and my family
my people Maya they're not real you and
I are real this isn't real okay good the
film deals with a lot of big themes like
what does it mean to be human and what
does it mean to be alive and can love
transcend those divides and boundaries
you're my friend should we embrace it
should we destroy it everyone ready and
action
Gareth shoots in a way that a lot of
actors love because he doesn't like to
cut
I love that process where we do these
rounds it just takes
he operates the camera himself you know
he knows what he wants yeah he's not
afraid to try anything and Anything Goes
we really went for broke it's just a
really insane Rich visual Journey that I
hope affects people in the way that I
was affected when Cinema blew my mind as
a kid
foreign